you around
during the kiss beanie [ __ ] yeah yeah
the craziest [ __ ] is
i always i mean listen oh wow i always
i've talked to kiss about i've talked to
beanie about it and i always say that
that's probably the closest
back and forth because i depending on
where someone's from or who you ask or
who they're
i thought both of them won i thought
that we was going to die or we was going
to kill one of them i swear to god
because at the end because because at
that time
nobody was realer than beanie siegel let
me tell you something or the locks and
yonkers
about beans i love beans beans had us
train us the young guns
like i was you could basically say the
young guns was a gang within state
property bro
because they was from their own part of
town in philly they had us train bro
like like beans had us train
and i i used to really sit here like oh
jadakiss is one of my favorite rappers
like the locks bro
i don't know the man i would be without
the locks right right right real [ __ ]
i'm talking about we all the streets is
like
the words is in my dna who i am as a
person so like
i used to be saying like we had a we had
a we had a situation one time
with them though what happened we was in
um
you remember sonny she used to be on
ninety seven she's sunday yeah
like hg tv but sonny had a birthday
party
in brooklyn and and she had this
birthday party in brooklyn and
jada was hosting it but she wanted the
youngest at the time we had cancer i
won't stop
so we they was hot everybody was booking
them so she wanted to do can't stop
won't stop
so we we had a show in va and
they was like by the time we get there
maybe kissing them and be out of there
so we get up to um we get the va i mean
we get to brooklyn from va
and um some philly dudes came and all
that [ __ ] or whatever
and
[Laughter]
somebody from sunny's team came to our
car was like hey
katie kiss is still here could y'all
wait until he leaves to come in
like and he was like yo you don't want
no problems so chris was like yeah right
and then chris sat there and while we
sitting there
like all these cars pull up and we see
like j hood get out
[ __ ] styles was locked up at the time
but j-hoo was there
a [ __ ] sheik and a bunch of dudes
right
so chris was like [ __ ] that we going in
there right
so they they go into the um
they go into the club they all walking
out with kiss
and uh chris is chris and neath manager
was like yo don't say nothing like don't
say none of them let them go ahead
yo they came outside and we're on the
line waiting to get searched i don't
know who it was but one of them was like
man
[ __ ] all that d-block [ __ ] what y'all
[ __ ] wanna do right
so then we get into the spec going back
and forth and then like chris is
standing there he gets searched and
like j hood him and j hood is like
saying [ __ ] to each other and all that
right this ain't no social media
nobody's seen this happen
we get in the room we get into the
studio
and we get in there i don't know what
this dude from philly who he was i seen
him one time that day i never seen him
again
it was all of us in the room he said it
was like 15 of us in the room he said
yo who in here ain't bring a burner like
four four five people raise their hand
he said i got burning for everybody who
ain't bring one
he's no i bro i swear i thought he was
gonna die that night man he like yo
when we come outside we're not letting
nothing we
going all the way right i'm like what
i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm like all right did he give you a
burner i'm not gonna say if he what he
gave me or he didn't
okay okay but um
we walk outside i think by that time
they had left
and then we go to baseline we have fun
that was it but like
damn bro i thought like we had a couple
yeah we had a couple like little run the
crazy thing about that is like i didn't
know i didn't know jd kiss at the time
jada kissed my man i love kids of course
his son j1 that's my man i love him chic
all of them bro like
styles ironically when styles and
styles came home who called my phone i
think green lantern
called my phone and that style was on
the phone
he's like y'all got styles on the phone
and he like oh um he want to talk to mac
and i put them on the phone they spoke
on my phone you know i mean and then
from there
years later me and stiles we built our
brotherhood i love styles i love his
wife his son
yeah i mean like i it's just crazy how
life works out but yeah
it's a few times bro but i always think
back to that time that jada went to the
the power show in philly like the the
big summer jam or whatever way
yeah yeah we did that we did that before
j j and i
did they [ __ ] nobody did the same thing
at hot 97 summer jam in new york
we did it at powerhouse okay okay so the
thing was we did kiss was doing
powerhouse
in philly in philly yeah nobody knew
beans was dead
beans put on a halloween mask and he
walked out on the stage
and when he was this at the same show
not the
not not the one you told him when he
dissed him okay this is years later
okay okay that happened in like oh two
this happened in like oh
five when oh five when beans came home
okay
we do powerhouse and kiss that's what
i'm saying
people be thinking that jay took
everything from them but like jay did i
declare war after that when he brought
out knives okay yeah
so beans it was on halloween we came out
beans he opened up his jacket and
everybody seen the sp chain and he took
the mask off and then they did reservoir
dogs
that's the first time that they had done
something together this is before
jay and knives reconcile this [ __ ] so
that was when they reconciled their [ __ ]
that's when they reconciled they [ __ ]
but they had talked pride they
reconciled this [ __ ] when when beans had
um
came home